le domaine de madame elisabeth avait
revêtu les couleurs de la fin de l'année
pour la deuxième année consécutive le
département des yvelines proposer son
comptoir de noël nous sommes obligés
hélas de fermer ces lieux dans l'année
parce qu'ils sont aussi des lieux on
travaille et c'est pourquoi je souhaite
que progressivement
nous on a travaillé ailleurs et que ces
lieux donc soit pour tous les héninois j
insiste découverte de poney projections
de films d'animation mais surtout
présence d'exposants une cinquantaine
d'artisans et producteurs étaient
présents avec un point commun ils sont
tous yvelinois c'est important pour les
gens qu'ils puissent retrouver des
créateurs des gens qui font vraiment de
la production bien sûr locales qui
permettent aussi de pouvoir avoir un
suivi qu'on puisse retrouver
nous notre clientèle et que les clients
puissent aussi suivre notre travail nous
voir nous revoir on est dans la mode du
locavore et les gens de plus en plus on
nous demande mais où sont vos ruche
comment vous produisez etc
ils veulent se renseigner ils veulent
adhérer à notre concept est justement il
adore et donc du coup ils achètent et
ils sont fidèles
elle cette année près de 12000 personnes
se sont laissées tenter par ce comptoir
de noël encore un peu de patience plus
qu'une quinzaine de jours avant que les
cadeaux se retrouve au pied du sapin